Speaker 1: Let's continue speaking to folks
via discord at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord. Let's go next to Jonah from
St. Louis. Jonah, you're on the air.
And David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, yeah, so I was watching a
previous episode and you're making a comment about
how more Republicans don't come out against Trump.
I think you referring to Paul Ryan at the time and
your reason was Paul Ryan was running for office.
You wouldn't have the courage to do so. But I
think we have a couple of really good examples of
politicians doing that in this chamber
and in Liz Cheney and Adam Kinzinger.
Speaker 1: Yes, there's no question. So I don't
remember if I said he he wouldn't. I mean, I
definitely said he doesn't have to worry
because he's not running. I'm not saying
he definitely wouldn't if he were running for
something, but it's just that he's not running
for anything right now. And right now he's free to
say whatever. But you're right. I mean, Kinzinger,
Mitt Romney, there are Liz Cheney. There are
people it's not even always that they're coming
out against Trump. They're just sort of telling
some truth that the Trump is they're unwilling
to hear like Joe Biden, really one. But I
think it's certainly easier when you're not
running for anything to just speak your mind.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I totally agree with that.
I guess my my point is that I think in another
episode know you were you were sort of downplaying
what Cheney and Kinzinger were doing, you know,
and then, you know, I guess highlighting what what
their downsides are more than than what, you know,
what they're currently doing to speak up against,
you know, Trump ism. Yeah. And, you know, I'm
wondering if that's a missed opportunity to
kind of make a better example of what's going on
there and then, you know, making it a safer place.
Right. For for people like them to do that.
Speaker 1: But here's the thing. You have to
remember the Liz Cheney told the truth that
Joe Biden really won. Liz Cheney still voted
with Trump's position 90 percent of the time. So
it's not that I was downplaying. The point was
this party has become so perverted that
just stating who won the election is
considered dissent, and that's crazy. But at the
end of the day, these are not my friends as a
progressive because they still agree with Trump on
just about everything. It wasn't about downplaying
or up playing. It was just about explaining
on policy. These are not people I agree with.
Speaker 4: I get that I guess it's I
guess, the little wind strategy, right?
Take what you can get. And,
you know, in this climate,
Speaker 1: the problem is how much are we
going to give them an atta boy just for
acknowledging who won the election? Like,
yes. Compared to many of their cohorts
there, they're doing something that's different,
but it shouldn't be something you get a it's sort
of like when parents use food as a reward and
they're like, you know, if you eat your veggies,
then we'll give you a pound of ice cream. And it's
like, no, no, no. Like, you just you get veggies
are part of the meal. You should you don't want
to use it as a you don't want to start using as
a reward something that should just be, hey, we
eat a balanced diet in this house and it's sort
of the same idea, like how much are we going to
really praise them just for telling us who won the
election? I get why, but let's not go overboard.
Speaker 4: And that makes sense. Appreciate it.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, yeah, thanks for
calling. And there's Jonah from St. Louis.